on nous dit le beacon s'il connaît
justement notables un chat bleu intense
au niveau international mais c'est pas
du tout ça on a une monnaie une monnaie
on attend justement qu'on puisse
conduire une politique menée on puisse
réagir à des événements le problème une
masse monétaire et feast comme l'était
lors autrefois tant fait on revient dans
le passé on revient deux cents ans en
arrière à l'époque on navigue masse
monétaire exogènes c'est à dire qu'ils
n'étaient pas déterminées par rapport à
l'activité économique et qu'on ne
pouvait pas piloter est ce que c'est ça
l'avenir monétaire est ce que ces
retournés de son temps en arrière avec
des masques exogènes au lieu d'avoir des
masses et rando jeunes évoluent en
fonction crédit et de l'activité
économique qu'on peut pas piloter ce
point en tout cas c'est l'état de
l'indépendance des banques centrales
parce qu'on ne peut pas faire de
politique monétaire avec le bic phone
vous n'avez même pas la possibilité des
sites et une politique monétaire donc
c'est un avenir monétaire avec le petit
hall là je suis d'accord avec monsieur
yves où c'est sûr que ça ça réduirait
drastiquement les émissions de gaz
de co2 gaz à effet de serre parce que
l'économie s'effondrait complètement
j'aurais plus d'économie on ne peut pas
faire de l'économie avec une masse
monétaire limitée non potable et qui est
complètement déconnecté de l'activité
économique donc d'un point de vue
monétaire c'est un dessin c'est exact
[Musique]